I'm not saying opening is mostly
strategic
yeah the longer the game goes the more
tactical it gets
um although I'm playing a more
confrontational opening so it's kind of
like chess like normal chess too
it could be tactical or positional
depending on
uh the overall structure
how open Things Are
Neil says hi
oh no my palm
oh novelty preventing Knight P4 but
allowing
the queen to come
I think I'll play this
preventing the queen from being attacked
now E5
I'm happy to be controlling the center
here
one idea is to play E4 and duck G1
preventing the knight from finding
safety
I think I'll go for that because duck G1
also prevents white from castling
and if Knight H4 then maybe G5
will trap the knights
and you'll could play Knight G5 and duck
duck E5 or duck F5 preventing Queen digs
G5
but then I played duck or I played Pawn
H6 and duck H3
effectively trapping the knights
not to mention this Bishop's also
attacked
so there's some issues for white to
solve here
I'm assuming like we might trade first
yeah no Knight G1
I want to play this to prevent weight
from casting
a nice Square for the bishop
oh
there's a funny line
that's a really funny line This is
actual oh no my queen
oh no my queen
oh it's so beautiful too look at this
I'll be very disappointed if Neil
doesn't take the queen
it looks capturable and then you move
the dock and your Rook can move
I hope I'm not missing anything I might
be missing something actually
and if white has to take back it's a
success
but look at this
Pawn digs G2 duck G1
I saw this but I I can Queen
and then duck G2
and not only am I attacking the king
but Neil's gonna have to move the duck
again which leaves the queen hanging
and now I'll just win the Knight
and then block the queen
saving my King opening up this what a
sequence
oh it's so pretty
and now I think it's just a matter of
developing
and we might do some
like back and forth between ducky 3 duck
F1
yeah I should also mention there's no
check in this oh
there's no check in this game
um the game ends when the
when one of the kings are captured
Play Bishop E7 ducky one
I have to be really careful here
actually
yeah hello to YouTube I'm already
thinking what to call this YouTube video
oh no my queen duck chess Edition
Okay so
yeah in Duck chess like when there's
double attacks like this
they're much easier to deal with because
the dock is so good at defending
no okay now everything's safe
might be winning the pawn soon
oh that's a funny move
can I can I take the pawn and play duck
F2
okay good job
wait take the pawn dog F2 Bishop E7
duck G2
[Music]
I'm trying to calculate
it's actually a really strong move wow
I have to be careful still
I could take the Rook actually
take the rook and then take the bishop
and then actually oh no my queen
I want to take on H2
but then I'm not sure about
Bishop E7
okay I have a better idea I'm gonna play
Queen G2
and Doc F2
oh no I'm getting mated
uh oh
don't meet me
don't Maybe
[Music]
hey it's St Louis chess club welcome to
duchess
shout out to St Louis chess club
we were seeing the final game of the
round with aronian trying to
pull off some stalemate trick
if you're just joining this is duck
chess
I just said oh no I'm getting mated
opponent deep in thought
yeah so let me just explain that if
Queen were to take
then I would just take back and place a
duck so the bishop doesn't defend and I
would win a queen
so Queen B5
move
um
now what to do maybe bishop D7
now I want to do the same thing actually
it doesn't work though because King
takes and then duck goes in between
um
I'm considering taking
I think I'll take I think this is simple
and then duck C6
is very good at blocking the checks
now Bishop D7
maybe 90s
I want to keep the bishop here but
maybe King E7
go for the bong cloud
a bishop D7
I all played duck C6
it looks counter-intuitive
but the point is
uh White's gonna have to remove the duck
from C6 regardless
um of the move and
I essentially attacked the queen in this
way
now I can play this
I might be losing a pawn but
that's okay
trying to figure out what to do if
the duck keeps being placed on f8 or G8
like how do I get this Rook into the
game I might end up playing King d8
oh B3
or maybe I'll just keep taking material
yeah ready to bring the knight in soon
maybe the bishop will come back into
it's so weird like in Duck chess even
when you're up so much material it still
takes a lot of work to win
the duck is such a good Defender
but I'll gradually come in with a rook I
over defended these things which is kind
of useful
ooh
okay I'll play Rook E8
and then duck E3
making progress I want to play Knight E4
very soon
maybe I can somehow achieve a smother
duck mate
except white doesn't really have enough
pieces to smother his own King
or preventing Rook C3
there's a lot of plans here once again
is to make a a new Queen which could
help
ooh fancy
gotta play this and then this preventing
Queen D5
I dare you to take my Pawn
okay now play this and then duck C3
guaranteeing that I'll be able to play
Queen C3 next move
it looks a little bit risky like I'm I'm
giving away some Pawns
but uh
yeah that's all with good intention so
now Doc F3
King has to move now
how to do this talk
where to move the duck
I think I'll hold off from taking the
pawn and play this and then duck F3
ready to take here
oh
okay look at this Knight B1
and then duck
A2 forces King A4
and then the duck will be on B5
still not winning though maybe I'll play
this first
doc F3
oh
where's my win
it's so frustrating okay Knight B1 duck
A4
yeah good defense but now I have this
move and duck F3 preventing Rook F3 or
Rook C3
and now I want a duck mate but I think
I'll just take the free Queen I'll tuck
me later
okay
let's play this and then duck B2
essentially check to the king
okay I think it was duck mate next move
like white could have maybe played this
and duck somewhere and I was just gonna
play this
and then I guess ducky won
oh it's still not over though
like if I play dog A3 there's this and
then duck B1
but then I do this and then duck A2 and
then there's no Escape